[Music]
myself the same question
literally no this this can't be
happening this you should what are you
doing here well I'll tell you that when
you tell me where here is if I play oh
do you want a selfie bro sorry we're not
no I'm also the flash those are the what
the flash flash flash complicated make
your outfit it seems like a comfy
there's this pretty cool you safe and
breathable by Barry Allen no what does
that mean this should be impossible now
it's be impossible now you don't know
about the oh my god don't do this to me
I don't know about the what okay
as possible welcome back everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my video all
about the crisis on Infinite Earths
Ezra Miller scene and the flash
flashpoint movie because there's a lot
of stuff going on and here obviously
there canonizing this to the air over
saying that all the Justice League movie
characters exists in an alternate
reality but we just got a bunch of new
details about the flash movie so we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the easter-egg videos we're doing a
flash ring giveaway we have two versions
of the flash here they're gonna
introduce the flash ring during the
flash movie so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from this crossover
scene on the video so they start this
off by having that funny moment of
Oliver Queen bopping Barry on the
forehead making him think that he has
unlocked his potential when really it's
meant to be more of a pep talk Barry is
as powerful as he's always been so he
goes around the speedforce collecting
all the Paragons in Oliver Queen's
consciousness from important moments in
their lives because the Speed Force is
this nexus of space-time where time
moves very differently and you sort of
create mental constructs of your own
realities wherever you want to be he
takes a wrong turn and winds up running
into the Ezra Miller flash from Justice
League inside a version of STAR Labs but
it's filmed as if it's happening inside
the Justice League movie universe of the
DC EU I talked about this on Twitter
some of you may have noticed this it's
the only scene from any of the crossover
episodes that's filmed in anamorphic
movie ratio so it's filmed as if it's
happening inside a movie the movie
universe of the Justice League movie the
reason they did this is to imply that
our Barry had travelled into a moment
from the Ezra Miller Flash's life so
it's our Barry running into Ezra Miller
it's not as Room Miller's Barry running
into our Barry so whatever was happening
before this moment Ezra Miller's flash
just happened to be inside the Speed
Force which is why he didn't get wiped
because at the end of their little
crossover moment he says this shouldn't
even be possible because as he's fading
out Barry is trying to tell him about
crisis on Infinite Earths and the fact
that the entire multiverse just got
wiped by the antimatter wave the Speed
Force protects them all from being white
because it exists outside of space-time
that's why all the Paragons
survive the antimatter way because they
were thrown into the speedforce by all
of her out of the vanishing point the
funny thing about this though is that
even though this is meant to be the
movie version of star lapse it looks
exactly like the TV show version of STAR
Labs it obviously should go without
saying that when they do get to the
flash movie his version of STAR Labs
will look different than this but they
had their funny introduction our Barry
has met alternate versions of the flash
before and alternate versions of himself
but until now they've all looked like
him that's the main reason why he's so
confused like this shouldn't even be
possible
why are you doing here the second reason
is because they're acknowledging the
meta aspect of having the movie
characters crossover with the TV
characters which usually is something
that you say is never going to happen
like it's super super rare to see that
happen in the case of like Clark Gregg
in the Marvel Universe he's one of the
few people that's gone back and forth
between the TV shows in the movies
samuel l.jackson did it but so far they
haven't really done that in a big way
with the DC movie characters at least
the current ones right now they also do
this to shine a light on some of the
drama that happened way back in 2014
when they first announced Ezra Miller so
there was a hot minute when they were
airing the first episodes of the flash
TV show way back in 2014 right around
that same time they announced Azra
Miller as the movie flash everyone felt
really weird about it because we're like
wait a minute
we thought that Grant Gustin was the
flash is he not gonna be the movie flash
if then eventually Ezra Miller and Grant
Gustin both came out and said that there
are total Broz they don't care about any
of that drama stuff so they don't have
any kind of beef between the two of them
in Mar Guggenheim the showrunner on
arrow and the lead writer on the crisis
on Infinite Earths crossover revealed it
was actually Warner Brothers movie
studio people that asked the arrowverse
people to put Azra Miller in the
crossover not the other way around you
think the TV show people will be the
ones trying to get the movie characters
they did reach out to Michael Keaton Val
Kilmer or a bunch of other Batman movie
actors but the movie people called them
and said please find a spot for Ezra
Miller they had already wrapped this
episode the arrow episode but they were
like hell yeah we can find a spot for
Ezra Miller so they brought in a bunch
of extra people on a separate day to
film this scene and then tag it on after
they'd already done the episode the joke
about Ezra Miller's Barry Allen not
knowing that he's called the flash is
just because they never called him the
flash officially during the DC movies
that he appear
Batman V Superman Justice League Suicide
Squad they'll give him the flash name
officially during the flash movie which
they did confirm was gonna be a version
of flashpoint I'll explain what's going
on with that in a second because a lot
of people have asked wait a minute does
that mean that Grant Gustin is gonna get
to cross over into the flashpoint movie
now as some sort of cameo add to that
they might not even premiere the
flashpoint movie until after the flash
TV show has ended its run so keep in
mind that it's still gonna be a couple
years before we see the flashpoint movie
they joke about each other's flash suits
the joke about Ezra Miller's flash suit
is that it looks cool but it's super
uncomfortable to wear it doesn't breathe
well and it's a bit awkward to walk
around in
that's why Azra Miller's flash says all
those things about Grant Gustin suit oh
wow it looks so comfy in the joke
obviously then about grant gustin's
flash costume is that it doesn't look
nearly as cool as Ezra Miller's flash
suit they will give Azra Miller a new
version of the flash shoot during the
flashpoint movie because I think the
idea is is that that movie's successful
they'll do sequels and in each new movie
you typically give the hero a new
version of a costume to sell way more
toys his new flash suit will probably be
a little less hardcore and a little more
comic-book accurate the other reason why
is Remillard flash is so confused and
weirded out by this moment is because he
hasn't learned about the existence of
the multiverse and hasn't met alternate
versions of himself yet he has travelled
through time though they did have that
time-travel moment during Batman vs
Superman they were going to pay that off
during one of the Justice League sequels
they had planned but that was when
Justice League was gonna be a trilogy of
movies I've already done a couple videos
about what the story of that trilogy was
going to be it was gonna play out very
similarly to Avengers infinity war in
Avengers end game the dialogue that he
fades out on is I told Victor this was
possible referencing Victor stone aka
cyborg meaning that he and cyborg at
some point had a conversation about the
possibility that there was a multiverse
and he could theoretically meet
alternate versions of himself it also
kind of makes me believe that they're
gonna have a cyborg cameo during the
flashpoint movie but this is them
canonizing the movie characters to the
arrowverse multiverse just saying that
all that stuff that henry cavill
Superman Ben Affleck's Batman all that
stuff happened in an alternate universe
somewhere getting to the flash
flashpoint movie stuff so they're
supposed to film that sometime next year
I believe after as
Miller finishes making the next
fantastic Beast movie even if you don't
care about the fantastic beast franchise
Warner Brothers cares more about it from
a financial standpoint because the Harry
Potter franchise has been more reliable
for them than the DC movie franchise
Ezra Miller is playing a main character
during those fantastic beast movies
that's why they're doing that movie
first then they're doing the flash movie
Warner Brothers has changed his overall
strategy and how it connects each of the
different movies but the movies that are
set in present-day after the events of
Justice League are mostly still loosely
connected but some will not reference
the other movies in really big ways like
the Aquaman movie only loosely
referenced the events of Justice League
but you didn't have any really big
Justice League crossover characters the
flashpoint movie will probably have a
few cameos but they're not gonna do the
exact plot of comic book flashpoint with
all the Justice League characters like
Wonder Woman Batman Superman I am really
hoping for a ben affleck batman cameo of
some kind even a small one because
jeffrey dean morgan who played thomas
wayne during Batman V Superman recently
said that it was time to put on a mask
again and said several times in the past
that he would love to play flashpoint
Batman in a heartbeat
right now the director of the flash
movie is Andy machete he's the person
that did both of the it movies so he
loves it a horror director is doing the
flash movie so maybe there'll be some
good scares during the flashpoint
reality that Ezra Miller's Barrie
creates by saving his mother they
haven't announced who their movie
version of the reverse flash is going to
be they probably won't cast him till
next year so I'll say Anthony star would
be an amazing reverse flash you all know
him as home lander from the boys TV show
he plays a fantastic psychopath
gentleman
[Music]
if the flash flashpoint movie does real
well I think the Profoto in the first
movie they can always do in the sequels
so let me know in the comments if the
movie version of flashpoint will be
smaller what do you want them to do with
the sequels and who do you want them to
cast as reverse-flash in the movies
there was a brand new flash episode 10
trailer for the post-crisis universe
I'll do a video for that sometime in the
next couple of days but leave all your
requests and big questions in the
comments congratulations Anthony
Lockhart you're the giveaway winner from
my last big DC video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details every one click here
for my full crisis on Infinite Earths
videos and click here for my new
spider-man Morbius trailer and sinister
six teaser thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you
[Music]